- Chloe, are you okay in there?
Do you need any help?
I'm coming in.
Honey, what the (beep)?
Yeah, this meeting is
gonna be about two hours.
Are you sure you don't
have to go to the bathroom?
- Yeah, I'm sure.
- Do you wanna just try?
I can take you.
It's not a big deal.
Hey Chloe, remember what we talked about
with the printer, how it's
really nice to take turns?
Why don't we let someone else use it?
And then you can come back
when they're finished.
- Why don't we go around and talk about
what some of our strengths
were this quarter?
- [Voiceover] Well, I think.
- Whoa, whoa, okay.
Why don't we raise our
hands if we want to speak?
- You wanna grab some lunch?
- Um, you can get lunch
after you've cleaned
your desk up a little bit.
It'll be so nice to come
back to a nice clean desk.
Oh, I can get those crusts for you.
Here, hold on.
No more crusts.
Bye-bye, crust!
- You're kidding me.
(beep)
- Language!
Oh my goodness.
I am so sorry that she
spoke to you that way.
It will never happen again.
- Alright guys, that about wraps it up.
Ah, thanks for coming.
We'll touch back next week.
(clap, clap, clap)
- I am so proud of you.
Oh my gosh, he worked so
hard on this presentation.
You rocked it.
Come here, sweetheart.
Did you wash your hands?
- Yeah.
- Let me smell.
(sniff)
You lied to me.
Time out.
Time out, I'm so disappointed in you.
- Can I borrow your phone charger?
- Hmm, what's the magic word?
- Abracadabra.
- No.
Hey, let me get that for you.
There you go.
All better.
- Alright, see you tomorrow.
- Oh, okay, drive safely.
And get to bed at a reasonable hour.
No snacks after eight p.m.
I love you.
(jazzy music)